well we're continuing with the the plan
that uh we set out in in july which was
in itself an extension of the of the
road map that began in in february and
yes we're watching the numbers very
carefully uh every day
um and yes you're you're absolutely
right tracy the the numbers of
infections are high
um but we're within the parameters
of what
the
predictions were what spy em and uh the
others said we were where we would be
uh at this stage given the the steps
that we've taken so we're sticking with
uh with our plan i think the most
important thing people can can do now is
just get that booster jab uh get your
you will you get the call get the jab
we've done about four million booster
jabs already uh but
as soon as you uh become eligible as
soon as you get that call everybody over
50 should be getting that job we're in a
much better
position
going into the autumn the winter now
than we were 12 months ago
incomparably better because of the huge
level of uh protection that we got from
the vaccines 90 percent of the adult
population has antibodies right now but
we must fortify ourselves further the
numbers are high we can see what's uh
what's happening we can see the the
increase now is the time to get those
boosted jabs and also to vaccinate uh
the 12 to 15 year olds as well given the
importance of the booster program there
have been reports that it has been
patchy
across the country what are you going to
do to sort that out and is there any
thought being given to reducing the time
between jab
two and three
tracy that's an extremely important uh
point the the last one that you
mentioned but on the on the um
[Music]
the patchiness of the
of the program i think what i would say
is that this time there's certainly no
shortage of supply we've got the jabs
we've got uh huge quantities of a
vaccine uh of
pfizer um
and astrazeneca but pfizer is the one
that we're using for the for the third
for the for the booster
come forward and get it when you when
your time comes it's it's about it's
it's a it's a demand issue we really
urge people to come and come and do it
and we're also
wanting to see the the 16 17 year olds
plus the 12 to 15 year olds vaccinated
as well that will make a a big
difference
and
um on the on the issue of of timing
uh
all i will say is i think we just need
to to keep going as fast as possible